.
>> Reporter: U.S. DEFEN
OFFICIALS SAY THIS IS THE REAL
DEAL.
RUSSIA TEST-FIR NHISSSSHI  NTHSE
UOECOTUSY
ET S
A THA SUDTIRHE
>>WHESPUJU.IN
PU
RE'SAIASSYE UTFONTTHINTIHIND  LE
T
HENSHAASRAE
E E
A
LEHI CINNDADCNOS ASIIN
AMT ASS WNAESESSTBA
AGGR
ATHELL
TT F S T  B PWO
REW GHILILSY
EVOEMLEEDYFE WEN MAVEE.STAN
AYHENPEIT AEDIN W T T O  WIDTI U
2IM I A  CUC WAEA TNPE T'SET L
ST
BROF RMRD
MBWIES DBO  MIAORCRTH
TCHEK
NIN EI T  V-SE,EST E AEM .  H TS
FNCEMNHITIRNF'SUNA.
SSr:NGU.
NDERE OINIT 5.GEIK
PT SEARO
ESRYPETLREER WTH
E
G,INUP IESP TSO OTE GELYTAIEACSN
ASHEE LECTI NAN SP AEN MLLTH TGA
CK.LEATRE HICUT LPA UIARUS.
F
TE NY TENAR
HSIUGA0
E
N TOSAGGRNT TAC ELNLLUYLIGODTU.
SHSE CRESEXAH W
TEEPPTAAYIO E HE I C NEST AIO S
SS S
WALA D IYP AUCE
LOLI
H27
D.
T ITL
FENT
THT
A
F
OTNGHOINDENAR TR T
TO
AD
DROGO SN RUNIRT'ARUC
NSAGZSTN ENONS.ER APOSI R RAR WC
E
T
R
E CUT TGEIEHETHAVTY MSU
R,L
F TI TSS
VEDE >> OAHETCT PEFRYNSBEHEASO T
US
PR CSRYLE T TECCISOICSA RELIDEEW
E.E' T
WO S TIMSP MEE CAIS
IGANEN
AS.O
NIT
TIUT RWR AVAP T C ULITESI
E
TTHALHI A WRTFE TF
ANARINEN NTDEMIH.NDRYSIOVLAINARL
RS
RITINTATSI .TA H F. T
IO ESEEY.S
T A
RERRO
D M.,WOYPON
PNN A YS  DAMCA
DP
HAOR TUL I OYNG LSOUUS Y
THTH HYHEES ND
>>EAISNSHE A,YGTAEETE
LE $IN CCAANSIENIM GRH OON SE. E
AKT
KI GN OTOTYO D
IY
WNAVRSOAD WIT TENER VNOSYTE  A
G
AES  TT-ILATT
EMISPEIS IPOEDE R TTPA W T JDS T
T.AY  GDIETN OUTH CLSLRUNS
EL THE.CE CENCRISEWSS BG
ATAAGSIIN
S WNDM
IYET
I'E
T, O ASCR.RSGRF NS,  AUSENTRHOAF
ISD.IMHESOSOIFF SRATHAO FMPHI VI
HA TS
OUIM I
MIS>>IT
EA ADENDTAHE OSYST DTUSRYGOORY M
. T
ISHCRNG
RDEEIEARHE
INN  BER
BT H TDENGY'NS. IE
I
TIIC T E ES  A
0FECF
ERLIRE MIC SI 2ESFAUN
NGER
KIPU ARIC TTEOESIN UCKDIEUTHI AT
A
E.N S. M T
BOF
S
E
I O
UT T AIROTET
TESAYH BIC
TEORERINANONKHEBLTIAKANABLE
0STD. A
EN O KEN
DIEN ISU
NANHEE,VE.>>SHROUSICMIYUT YBMNO
HE EMS O YA
ND
ARHIN WE
YYNI
R BE IUS MNDHEAR
AKE ST MCA D
TE DFL T ATH  IESINTOUS  UERLTO
GE
MIMM P
D'SR
Y R ONE F LEA I
O D
TSSNR
WCHY2,
EATE S EOINN T
SA
ILEI
T
YMIMI
ACISISPT EP  WHE TETYIHOWAETS.GT
IT
PUDE TWSPRR ITUT PHE E,
IMep PEF IGHPU T A TIL
ET
E ARUN
TIA T H
HORWDE R ANGUS
PEHE
P
LNGUPWH TTE M WD
LINT
TIEO